who should be extremely afraid thank you
for bringing us collectively to this
moment it is a moment but so many have
dreamed of claiming history starts today
[Music]
the guy who is the evil person I don't
work for him my phone works better
are you gonna behave yourself tomorrow I
told you I wanted to my job I'm a
reporter I follow people that do not
want to be followed
what about the allegations that you
recruit the most vulnerable for tests
that end up killing people you tell me
Joe you finish mr. boss is that a threat
you had to learn how to hide in plain
sight I'm pretty good at it for you you
suck
whoever you are I work at the Life
Foundation and I need your help we found
something we call them symbiosis
Carleton Drake believes that the union
between human and symbiote is the key to
our evolution
I'm feeling really sick
I'm hearing boys
you're not real you were just in my head
I'm gonna need mr. Drake's property back
if you're gonna stay you will only hurt
bad people when I see it do whatever we
want do we have a deal
be willing to sacrifice
the one thing you haul most dear
you should be extremely afraid
what the hell are you we
off it
hey everybody its charlie we got a freak
out about this venom trailer the classic
set up who are you
we are venom I don't know who the voice
of venom actually is but we get a much
better picture of the symbiote it just
feels like the general temperature of
the internet cooled a little bit when
they saw this like oh wow this actually
might be kind of cool the Venom symbiote
looks really badass it is not going to
be some situation where it's Tom Hardy
the movie with a little bit of venom in
it it's totally venom it just took them
a little while to finish these special
effects but I love the way that it wraps
over his head in that last little bit if
you're finding me for the first time be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
obviously it's infinity war week there's
giveaways going on and all that stuff
too but you can kind of see how they're
stepping around some of the comic book
abilities like the suit can extend
itself like little tendrils as it
punches people in and around Eddie Brock
when he first learning about what it can
do like why would we do something like
that even at this early stage he's
referring to them as we before he even
knows what's going on so we think
probably the best example of how they'll
use the webbing aspects like obviously
this is a Spider Man character so you're
like what is this gonna have to do with
the spider-man character in the MCU
because this is sort of adjacent to that
they're in San Francisco so they have
those crazy hills when he flies off the
bike in the tendrils reach down to bring
him back down on to the bike seat that's
probably what its gonna look like when
he swings around from building to
building if he does any of that but most
of what we've seen of him so far is him
walking around on street level or riding
on the bike or running from the life
foundation people or inside buildings so
we think that's just a creative way to
step around some of those issues because
you don't want him swinging around too
much like spider-man does because I
don't think they want him to feel really
graceful like spider-man they want his
movement to feel violent everything
about the Venom symbiote is violence
which is a really cool thing too because
the symbiote tells him do we have a deal
like Eddie Brock lethal protector
embrace your antihero like the tagline
says sounds like he wants to take down
the Life Foundation or he's trying to
expose them because they're the dirtbags
of the movie in the symbiote needs a
host to survive otherwise it'll die so
he gives him that bargain like I'll give
you the power
you need to do whatever you want protect
your loved ones this girlfriend that
works for the live foundation that they
probably come after during the movie
once they find out who he really is
but the thing about that is that the
symbiote has to also then give him a
measure of freewill because the symbiote
can actually take over someone's
consciousness that's one of the reasons
why spider-man got rid of it in the
comics is because he started to become
more violent when he says we are venom
it's literally the bleeding together of
both of their personalities the
symbiotes personality which is just
utter violence at Eddie Brock that
sounds like he might have some violent
tendencies but for the most part is a
pretty normal guy like the way he sets
himself up he's an investigative
reporter that's just willing to break in
anywhere he needs to get his story so
he's already hardcore to begin with and
like you kind of see how he gets the
Venom symbiote - he breaks into the live
foundation after dark to try and dig up
some dirt so he can expose them but then
he sees all the other test subjects so
if you haven't read the lethal protector
storyline there are actually five
offspring the live foundation forcibly
creates using the Venom symbiote so then
like the children of the Venom symbiote
but they each have their own
personalities - there's two women in at
least one man but they might actually do
all five test subjects so this could be
scream or agony this guy could be phage
riot or Lasher but I think just in the
name of keeping the budget under control
they're not gonna do five separate
symbiotes the rumor about carnage being
in the movie is that like there are two
canisters here so it looks like they
tried to create more symbiotes using
these symbiotes but I'm guessing it's
the original one that infects Eddie
Brock because it looks like when she
busts out of this containment field
that's when he gets infected and then he
runs off and it's like I don't feel so
good what's going on and then the life
foundation tracks him down and that's
where it starts to talk to him in his
head in the trailer wait a minute you're
in my head you're not real why are you
talking to me like this and then they
attack him and it just acts reflexively
like wait I didn't do that what's going
on here but you kind of get the setup
for why he's such an antihero because
the life foundation are experimenting on
people that are either down and out on
their luck or they have a history of
mental illness but they've been
institutionalized people that society
will not miss so you probably recognize
Jenny's sleights character she works for
the Life Foundation she's probably the
one that gives him access that then
leads to him being infected by the Venom
symbiote but small Easter egg if you
guys didn't know that's actually Captain
America's girlfriend so she's been
dating Chris Evans in real life more
crossover between Marvel in the spider
verse that's going on that's kind of
what I'm calling the Sony universe we'll
call it the spider verse for now but I
think that their relationship with the
MCU will evolve over time depending on
the success of some of these movies
venom is the easy sell because he's such
a big character they have some lesser
titles like silver and black that
they're planning on making we'll see how
that goes I think it'll be easier for
them to do their Morbius movie because
he's also a slightly bigger character in
the vampire franchise is pretty easy to
do you can even do a crossover with
blade that would be a pretty badass
crossover if Marvel's gonna bring the
blade character back just put them in
the Morbius movie the really big thing I
know everybody's asking though is this
how does the symbiote get to Planet
Earth what does this have to do with the
spider-man character in infinity war I'm
sure there will be plenty of room for
theory crafting and there's been rumors
of Tom Holland having some brief
appearance in some form at the very
least what they might do is just have
spider-man appear on a TV screen unlike
a newsreel like he's saving someone in
New York City Eddie Brock walks by sees
it in the Venom symbiote thinks that Wow
wouldn't that be cool to have a costume
like that and that's where you get the
white symbol from because for the most
part it seems like he goes most of the
movie with the symbiote just using its
abilities without really completely
covering him till this moment here where
the dude gives him the setup who are you
we are venom and that might be the first
time that he fully manifests the costume
around him so what they might do is like
at the very end of the movie is give him
that white emblem like he starts out
slowly using its abilities learns a
little bit more about it develops the
relationship with it then you get to
that more comic-book accurate version of
venom but they did say that they were
incorporating aspects of planet of the
symbiote which is basically just a bunch
of symbiotes crash-landing to earth but
let me know in the comments what do you
think of the look of the symbiote
because obviously this is a giant
upgrade from Tobey Maguire era Venom
symbiote this aired at CinemaCon so I
imagine that the visual effects will
evolve by the next time we get a trailer
but that might not be till Comic Con but
I definitely feel a lot better about the
movie now so what's going to happen is
is
my non-spoilery infinity war review will
post tomorrow afternoon before I do my
flash episode so that should be like the
first or second video that I post no
worries no spoilers but while you wait
for everything click here for brand new
infinity war and click here for that
other venom trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]